What does the coup mean for United States
and Turkey relations?
You know, there's going to be a real rough
patch coming soon.
Turkish media, which is pretty much all state
controlled at this point, has basically said
that the United States had some complicity
in this.
The reason for that conspiracy, which is nonsense,
is because Fethullah Gulen, a Pennsylvania-based
cleric who's an exile from Turkey, has been
accused by Recep Tayyip Erdogan of leading
this.
There's not much evidence there, but Erdogan
is demanding that the United States extradite
this cleric.
And if we do extradite him, he might ultimately
face the death penalty inside Turkey.
Now, this is reminiscent back in 1979 when
Ayatollah Khomeini demanded that the Carter
administration extradite the Shah, who like
Gulen, was in the United States for medical
treatment.
Declassified Soviet documents show that Carter's
willingness to do that, he exiled the Shah
to Panama, ended up being a factor in the
Soviet Union deciding that the United States
was too weak to counter the Afghan invasion.
So what will the coup mean for US-Turkey relations?
Let us know in the comments, and let us know
any other topics you'd like AEI scholars to
address in 60 seconds.